the ongoing protests against racial
injustice in America and the targeting
of public monuments that many judge
should be symbols of white domination
police in Washington DC clashed with
protesters who tried to knock over a
statue of President Andrew Jackson last
night Jackson has been criticized by
protesters for his role in slavery and
the removal of Native Americans from
their land Kris Van Cleave is outside
Lafayette Square near the White House
where the statue for now still stands
Kris what do you see today well good
morning you can hear the sound of trucks
they're installing barricades behind us
the statue back there between us and the
White House it is an iconic picture
outside the White House here in
Washington just a few minutes ago
President Trump tweeted that he has
ordered federal police to arrest anyone
who vandalizes or attempts to destroy a
statue a monument on federal property
he says they could face up to ten years
in prison now the unrest began here
yesterday afternoon and it was a marked
change from the protests we've seen in
recent weeks here in DC protesters broke
through a fence surrounding the statue
of President Andrew Jackson who was a
slave owner and attempted to pull it
down using ropes officers swarmed the
area there are reports they tried to
clear the crowd with pepper spray and
used a bicycle barricade to push
protesters back a witness tells CBS News
she saw rubber bullets being fired
several demonstrators tried to set up
barriers outside the White House and
declared what they called the Black
House autonomous zone the acronym be h
AZ was spray-painted on the historic st.
John's Church across from the White
House it's an apparent reference to a
similar space in Seattle that president
Trump's railed against in his Tulsa
speech and the president said vandals
could face up to 10 years in prison
under the 2003 veteran's memorial
Preservation Act it's not immediately
clear how many people were arrested here
we can tell you that here Jackson has a
complicated history on one hand he's a
war hero from the war of 1812 he's on
the $20 bill and his portrait hangs in
the Oval Office the other deal is you
said he's been criticized for his
handling
Native Americans in was a slave owner
okay Chris thank you